I was finally home I had just moved back
from Johannesburg South Africa where I
had been living for two years I was
Thanksgiving was a few days away and I
was sitting it on the couch with my dad
watching the news coming out of Ferguson
Michael Brown was dead and they had just
decided not to indict Darren Wilson not
even give him a trial what my dad looked
at me and he said what did you expect to
happen I mean if it was dark and a black
guy came at me with something in his
hand and a hood on I mean I could have
done the same thing
I stood up shaking and I looked at my
dad and before I ran out of the room I
said you are a racist I didn't
understand how my dad could have said
that his dad was a Dixiecrat defense
lawyer like Atticus Finch and to kill a
mockingbird
he'd spent his whole life fighting for
justice and equality that was the reason
why I had gone on to study racism as an
American Studies major in college at the
University of Virginia but the racism
that I studied was an extreme slave
owners were racist Ku Klux Klan members
were racist separate-but-equal racist
but me my family we were good so how
would I just called my dad a racist
conflicted I needed to figure it out
and when I learned is that racism is not
black and white
it is not binary instead it is a
spectrum and we are all wired to be on
it but when we talk about racism we put
up walls so to take those walls down
today we're gonna coin a new term we're
gonna call it Oh didi other deficit
disorder
with a deficit of the other in our lives
we have a disorder that causes us to
unintentionally avoid discriminate and
harm this is how we're wired we get OD D
from two sources direct experience and
indirect exposure to stereotypes when I
reflected on my OD D I realized that I
started when I was five now I was about
to start school and I was still sucking
my thumb and my mom who's here in the
audience is probably still embarrassed
she was horrified so she went she
consulted her brother-in-law my uncle
Robert and he had a solution you see
uncle Robert was Chinese and he had a
secret potion that he painted on both of
my thumbs that made them taste like
rotting Brussels sprouts from that
moment I needed uncle Robert and from my
limited five-year-old perspective I
didn't know any other Chinese people so
I thought that all Chinese people were
bad and should be avoided and it sounds
silly but 20 years later I looked around
I still didn't have any clothes Chinese
friends this is how we're wired this is
made even worse every day by the
indirect stereotypes that we absorb in
American media for example black men
play violent roles 56 percent of the
time while white men play them only 11
percent Asian men on the other hand are
often portrayed as effeminate nerds but
why it goes back to 1850 San Francisco
when 4000 Chinese immigrants flooded
into the city and only two were women
white men felt threatened by these new
eligible bachelors and so they used
political cartoons to brand them as a
feminine making fun of them for doing
girly work even though those were the
only jobs available as a result the
American public came to expect Asian men
who might be good at math but not at
wooing women all because white men
150 years ago were afraid of losing
their ladies this is how were wired
I mentioned that I studied racism in
college but while I spent afternoons in
the library getting all fired up about
the injustice of separate but equal I
came home to a different kind I was in a
sorority in college was actually
president of my sorority in college and
I know a lot of you are already bringing
negative stereotypes in to make
judgements about me but we won't talk
about that today but aside from all of
the negatives there are a lot of
positives too and one of the positives
is that you get to live with all of your
best friends all the time but when I
think back to that house of 146 people
there is only one person of color Lamont
our cook
we hadn't tried to keep the other out
but we had tried to bring people like us
in the result is discrimination and you
don't lose that bias when you're looking
for friends looking to hire someone or
looking for a life partner this is how
we're wired even more dangerous than
discrimination though is unintentional
harm Stanford psychologist Jennifer
Eberhardt studies implicit racial bias
and its impact on our behavior in one
study she showed participants images of
either black men or white men and then
uh fuzzy images of objects that slowly
became clear as a result when the
objects were crime-related and
participants had been shown images of
black men they were able to identify
them that much faster
Eber Hart's work suggests that we are
culturally conditioned to associate
black men with crime so my dad may have
been right about the impact that culture
had had on him we are all wired with OD
D and asking yourself where am I on this
spectrum is a really hard question to
ask because the answer often hurts when
I talk about this I feel sad and I feel
a tremendous amount of shame but when
I'm able to separate myself Who I am
from the mistakes I've made and the
mistakes that were made before me I feel
empowered and the most important message
I have for you today is that no matter
how we're wired on this spectrum we have
an opportunity to do some rewiring the
turning point for me
came when I moved to South Africa and
when you start talking about it it's
okay to say I'm white you're black it's
not just okay it's necessary because
when we tiptoe around the topics the way
we do here we give them power by saying
nothing the only thing you're doing is
is making sure that nothing changes what
if instead we stayed open we're curious
ask questions and if we're uncomfortable
as we will be it's okay
today we're uncomfortable and then ask
anyway because once we start the
conversation then we can actually start
to build the relationships that rewire
racism when I arrived an African
Leadership Academy to teach in
Johannesburg I had created a situation
accidentally in which I have become the
other so much so that my students
nicknamed me Leblanc as if I couldn't
crack that code but after a few weeks at
a la African other became Nigerian
Rwandan Senegalese Kenyan individuals
and when you can see diversity within an
other racial group it becomes really
hard to hold on to the stereotypes that
you came in with that African other
became some of my closest friends who I
still talk to daily because when you're
able to find common ground that's deeper
than the color of your skin you're able
to make connections that last longer -
this is a process this is a hard process
this is a long process this is something
I'm still working on I'm still working
on rewiring the OTD that I developed as
a child by building a relationship with
my roommate here at Stanford who is full
of joy a fantastic cook looks awesome in
hats and his Chinese she just happens to
be a little bit nicer than uncle Robert
was to me
I'm still working on this
we all have Oh didi but when we stop
accepting what others have shaped for us
and start shaping it ourselves then we
can rewire racism thank you